[Music]
again I want to thank you all for and
brownie you're doing a heck of a job
FEMA directors working 24/7 CBS FEMA as
well as the hosts of the Michael Brown
radio show Michael Brown
welcome to the Reuben report hey Dave
good to see you good to be with the eggs
you know this is the first time we've
ever done this where we played a ten
second clip let me get do you have any
idea well I can't I can't even imagine
what you might be talking about yes
I've struggled with it for a little
while because I thought do I want to go
right in and throw this right at him
sort of the infamous moment or do we
want to ease into it but then I thought
let's just let's just get it out there
because it it is what it is it's a
seminal moment in my life yet there's
there's before that moment then after
that moment yeah all right there are
many many reasons that I'm glad to be
sitting here with you because I think
we're gonna get into so many of the
things that we talked about on the show
all the time about the role of
government and the difference between
local government and federal government
all of these agencies and red tape and
all that but also that for that moment
and what happened for the months and
probably years after and actually even I
wouldn't I was googling you this morning
all the 10 year anniversary at we're
still pissed on you and all that stuff
it has a lot to do with just sort of the
general outrage culture and blame
culture and all of that so right we're
gonna do a lot here so first let's just
start with that moment though and then
and then I want to do everything else
back sure okay just tell me a little bit
about the days leading up to Hurricane
Katrina I it became clear to me probably
within well it came clear to me the day
after the storm made landfall because I
was on a Black Hawk helicopter with
former senator Mary Landrieu and we were
supposed to be going straight to the
Superdome to meet with mayor Nagin who I
always like to joke is remind people
he's still in federal prison
and in I'm sitting there and I'm not I'm
just kind of reading my notes from my
staff and I look out the helicopter and
I realize that we're going the wrong
direction across Lake Pontchartrain and
I asked the pilot were you going and he
said well the senator has asked that we
go check her cabin before we go to the
Superdome I was livid so now I have a
sitting united state senator next to me
who's just overridden what I said we
need to be doing and what the priorities
are I have the governor sitting next to
her who doesn't have the wherewithal to
say to the senator you know what your
cabin is not our priority the priority
is the people of New Orleans it was a at
that moment that I realized that I had
walked into a state that was so much
more corrupt I've been involved in
politics since I was literally six years
old that it was just so corrupt and it
was so dysfunctional
that I knew that everything that I had
in my hand about how things should
operate we're gonna start going out the
window okay I think that's actually a
perfect story to now start with your
childhood let's just let's just get a
little bio to you because I think that's
really interesting and what led you to
eventually be the director and then
we'll go through everything else right
so just tell me a little bit about
growing up was your family political
what sort of got you into this world Oh
Mike you know my family was kind of
political when I think about it I mean
my mom is 86 87 years old
and she still works for the Election
Board she still does the little local
elections in the little town that I grew
up I think you have to be over 80 to
work at the exactly I think there's a
requirement she's been doing it since
she was in high school but when the
first Republican governor of Oklahoma
was running he was at state party
chairman a guy by the name of Henry
Bellmon was coming out to the Oklahoma
Panhandle and they recruited me at six
years old to be the little kid to hand
to push cards out as he walked these
rural streets of Oklahoma so I just grew
up in this political family that was
always involved and of course you know
involved in student council and you know
in college and young Republicans and all
of that and so politics has just always
been a part of my life yeah and now he
thought I understood politics until I
got to Washington DC
and until hurricane katrina and they
just gave me an entirely different
perspective yeah but anyway long story
short you know I took the typical route
graduate from high school to my my my
wife is my childhood sweetheart her dad
actually delivered me wow that's the
kind of small town we grew up in
Wow we've been married for gosh forty
some years I don't want to say how many
and you know went to law school raised
two children very successful very very
successful children and just had a
pretty normal life except that I knew I
wanted to be a lawyer but I always had
this thought process that you never turn
down and you always look at an
opportunity and if an opportunity looks
good you take that opportunity even if
it's off the path you thought you were
going to take and so that's led me to
these incredible incredible experiences
in my life that most people don't do
because they become lawyers and all they
do is practice law their entire life
yeah That's not me so what was the first
one of those moments when you thought
well there's a good opportunity a little
little to the right off that exit the
home Republican Party came to me and
asked me to run for Congress back in
1988 promised me all of this money that
they were gonna in fact that governor
who was the first Republican governor
went on to be a u.s. senator and then
came back he was a big supporter of me
but I was running Henry Bellmon yeah
former US senator he was involved in the
Panama Canal treaties and everything but
the Oklahoma Republican Party recruited
me and said you know come on we really
want you to run and so I let Eagle get
in the way and I ran against a 12 term
Democrat incumbent in a gerrymandered
district where I got my butt beat but it
was it was an experience that again
most Americans never do most Americans
never throw their hat in the ring and
actually go out and say I'm gonna do it
and I would encourage people whether
it's a city council County Commissioner
state representative whatever it is if
you don't like the way things are going
if you're gonna [ __ ] about I don't
really hear about it unless you're
actually involved doing something
doesn't mean you have to run for office
but you got to be involved yeah it's so
funny after that
that you've been through I guess it's
maybe it's not funny it's either ironic
or perfectly poetic but that still is
your message as someone that you know we
sort of put up as the poster boy for
everything that's wrong with women Dave
let me tell you it may be poetic but it
sorry I quit pointing it's the lawyer it
is I could tell you so many stories
about how dysfunctional state I'm at
I've been involved as a city councilman
I've worked at state legislature as a
finance director didn't you go on I'm
the Undersecretary of Homeland Security
I have seen I have been inside the
bowels of the government and I can tell
you how it works and it is not what most
Americans think yes and we're gonna get
to all of that so the Under Secretary of
Homeland Security that is the director
of FEMA correct that's the gross just
sort of the the more technical term for
that were you involved in the
administration before 9/11 or was it
after the bats when bush no peg you for
no we I was there yeah and in fact I was
in Montana
getting ready to deliver a speech to the
national emergency managers Association
about the role of FEMA in terrorism on
9/11 2001 so you were the director of
him at that time I was I was a general
counsel at that okay and we ended up on
c-135 going back to Andrews Air Force
Base Joe all ba who was the director at
the time immediately went went to ground
zero on that Wednesday morning and I
went to the White House and just spent
the next gosh seems like year just day
in and day out just planning getting
ready for we didn't know what yeah
what's the one thing that really sticks
out in your mind about that day itself
for the first time you you are you're
flying alone there are no planes in the
sky you're flying alone some Airmen
asked me if I want to go down in the
tanker Bay and and just watch as we fly
across you know middle America and I'm
listening on the on the headset and the
only chatter you hear are among the
fighter jets that are flying around the
country and when I landed it was not
knowing it was like there was this blank
wall in front of us
none of us knew what was going to happen
next and so we meet in the Roosevelt
Room in the Situation Room that next
morning to get briefing by the CIA and
everybody else
and I remember just this this quietness
in the room that everybody knew that
none of us knew what we were facing yeah
was there a feeling that George W Bush
was the right guy to handle this because
for all the frustrations that people
right may have with him and that perhaps
you have related to some rug with
Katrina we can get into that right
I do remember at the time and I lived in
New York City at the time so I was there
for 9/11 Roy family was there my grandma
was there my know my dad I do remember
that between George W Bush at the time
but particularly Giuliani I think there
was at least a feeling that these guys
are sort of the right people to be
handling this at the time certainly
Giuliani at least from a New Yorker yes
perspective did you did you feel that
did people feel that within the
government that like that Bush was kind
of able to handle this or have the real
skill set to handle yes it was for me it
was more the most I mean I can still
remember vividly that day in the in the
Roosevelt Room
you've got Tolan Powell you've got
Donald Rumsfeld you've got condi rice
you've got Andy card so you have all
these heavy hitters and here's little
old me sitting at the table too and I
remember watching because I just I'm I'm
an observer of people and I remember
watching all of them and there was none
of the usual because I've been in these
meetings before and there was none of
the usual hey how you do and everybody
was at the table everybody was reading
their briefing everybody was trying to
understand we know that we always
referred to the President as the boss we
know the boss is going to ask some tough
questions and we know we're not gonna
have answers and that's indeed what
happened
you know we had theories we had ideas we
had plans but nobody really knew for
certain Mo's next yeah and especially in
those first few days where we didn't
know if another attack was coming or
what was actually the job of FEMA for
those first few days we are were the
nation's federal first responder we
coordinate all of for example the
Pentagon Ground Zero our job was to make
sure that we had
all of the urban search-and-rescue teams
deployed that we take care of the
firefighters we provide all the
equipment we provide the training we do
all of that stuff so our job was to
clean up Ground Zero our job was at the
Pentagon to help clean that up and what
was fascinating about it was normally
you go to a disaster it's not also a
crime scene but in this case both the
Pentagon and and and in in in
Pennsylvania and obviously in ground
zero
they were also crime scenes so we now
had to coordinate talking about
federalism so now we had to coordinate
you know the federal government state
government local governments and on top
of that we had to coordinate with the
CIA the FBI the NSA and everybody else
who's doing all of the forensic work how
does that go I mean one of the things we
talk about here a lot is sort of the
unwieldy giant government we have right
now sort of all the middlemen and
bureaucrats that get in the way
everything I mean how did it really go
if that's your job here's what's
fascinating when the government's under
pressure like that everybody does what
you have to my mother-in-law had to say
that drill Mike drives my wife like
crazy dude she's now deceased but it was
you know sometimes you just have to do
what you have to do and when when a
crisis hits of that magnitude it's all
hands on the deck and if you need to
break the rules people are willing to
break the rules to make things happen so
I would say that in in those intense
moments that's probably when the
government tends to do the best job
because everybody's trying their hardest
to do what's best for the country yeah
so how soon after that did W tap you to
be the head of FEMA let's see so shortly
after I became the deputy DRI I'd say
like just a couple of months later I
went from general counsel to deputy
director then they announced the
creation of the department well it's a
story about the creation of DHS yeah so
they're gonna create the DHS so W points
me to the transition team or one of five
people putting together the department
and I apologize to the nation for that
because I've got lots of regrets about
DHS I'm happy to die yeah we will
and then soon thereafter Albaugh left
and that's when I became the
undersecretary and the director of FEMA
so probably within gosh a year yeah boy
and then and just just it's the
mailman's story you know you start in
the mailroom and you work your way up
yeah and only two years after that then
the other crisis in years over here
certainly so tell me a little bit about
your regrets creating the Department of
Homeland Security
here's a backstory first that most
people don't know the administration was
opposed to the creation of the
department we thought it was a mistake
we're gonna create this massive
bureaucracy why things are working the
way they're supposed to work but
Congress felt this political desire that
you have to be seen doing something so
once Congress said hey we're gonna move
forward with legislation then the White
House says oh my god now we've got to
get in front of this because we want to
control it and and mold it in our only
view not Congress's view because in
effect they don't want to get
legislation put on his desk
that he they exactly dough and then it's
like these against all right there
exactly so Kay so our job was a great
example of how screwed it is so so I'm
thrown me and four other guys with clay
Johnson the president's best friend
college roommate deputy director of OMB
we're thrown together to create this
massive new bureaucracy by taking 22
different cultures 22 different cultures
22 different organizations and throwing
them in together and trying to make it
work what are a couple of those
organizations that were I mean it's
everybody right well it was secret
Secret Service what the hell Secret
Service doing in Homeland Security the
the Coast Guard the Coast Guard has this
kind of schizophrenic role they've
worked for homeland security yet they're
subjected to the military code of
conduct and they kind of technically
work for the Pentagon so we've got all
of the you've got that you have ice
Customs and Border Patrol immigration
you different grants for the Department
of Justice FEMA everybody had a
different culture and my objection was
you can't throw different cultures
together and really expect them to work
either in the short term in the long
term every organization corporate
private governmental has a culture and
trying to meld those is the one of the
most difficult things to do
look I love carly fiorina consider her a
friend but they brought Carly in to talk
to us about how to do mergers and
acquisitions and I'm thinking wait a
minute
the HP merger and acquisition that
didn't seem to go too well and you're
gonna tell us how to do this twenty-two
government agency thing I mean that's
one objection then the second objection
was you know we got of airports with a
major concern and for whatever reason we
wanted to blame the private contractors
who have a vested interest in making
sure that the airlines are secure right
but that's not good enough
instead let's fire all of them and let's
create this massive new bureaucracy
called the TSA and I'm unlike the kid in
the back of the classroom that keeps
raising his hand and saying but
professor why how's that gonna work but
there was just hadn't what would happen
when you said something like that cuz
now I think in 2018 if you say something
that the TSA most people agree with you
11 unwieldly ridiculous
moderation the reaction was always well
we're gonna meet your objection by doing
why and I had been around the block long
enough to know that that answer was BS
but when you're the one person out of
five you're outvoted so you you tend to
there's a great Washington Post story
that talks about brown as the
bureaucratic in fighter and I was and
the post writes it is if that's a bad
thing and I considered a badge of honor
because I was fighting for just the
reality that when you tell me that
putting these two put these different
agencies together is gonna be budget
neutral that's BS when you tell me
you're going to create TSA but you're
gonna prevent them from ever being a
union that's BS because I just know how
government metastasizes and so the TSA
has turned out to be what I thought it
was the dysfunction within DHS while it
may be minimally better it's still a
dysfunctional organization so let's back
up for a second cuz you mentioned that
before this the security was it all done
by private companies before the TSA
that's almost hard to believe was it was
it all done by private yeah
the airlines who have who has the most
now you think about just trying to
figure out what's the best way to put a
program together well who has the most
interest in making certain that their
planes are never hijacked or flown into
buildings oh the airlines why don't we
let them decide security because what do
they they have competing interests they
want to make sure their planes are
secure their passengers are safe but
that the security operates in the most
efficient and effective way now you tell
me
government's gonna care about those
three things bs yeah well it's also so
interesting because it's like what a
great way to use competition in the
right sense it's like this airline
that's doing it the right way yes where
they could go you know what look at our
marks on security so we're charging you
five dollars more and a lot of people
wouldn't have a problem with it right it
would it would be a beautiful thing I
didn't realize that it was fully private
before that yes Wow any other I mean
that's a well it's a pretty big issue
but any other big regrets related to
yeah well well for example we had within
FEMA what was called the catastrophic
disaster response group everything has
an acronym so was the CDR G and because
the FEMA director under under federal
law when in times of disaster reports
directly to the president you're the
president's representative so this C DRG
when there was a disaster like 9/11 we
brought all the cabinet departments and
agencies together so you usually had the
deputy secretaries there because they
were there on behalf of their bosses and
we would deconflict policy we would set
priorities and if State Department
wanted to do one thing but deal do you
wanted to do another and AG one to do
something else that was where we got all
of those D conflicted because the FEMA
director had the authority of the
president sitting in that room well
that's gone away now and you've thrown
these all together and I've always said
if you want to find out whether a
disaster is being handled properly or
not or any sort of crisis this could be
in the private sector to ask this
question
who's in charge if you can't answer the
question who's in charge then it's a
cluster
is there an inherent sort of there's a
conflict here which is that basically
you're taking government people and for
someone like you that maybe wanted less
government right and I think this is
what you're really saying about Bush at
the beginning of this didn't want this
the image didn't run right but
government and this is the problem with
libertarians in general it's like people
that want less government well if you're
in the government it's hard to look
around the office and be like guys you
know most of us probably shouldn't even
be here
you know we're gonna need new job guys
so in FEMA first started in 1979 under
Jimmy Carter they had a policy of
providing ice to hospitals so that
lactating mothers had a place where they
could keep milk where you could keep
insulin and other medicines that require
pharmaceuticals that require
refrigeration that ice was for hospitals
to provide their local communities a
place for the medicines to say stay cool
and safe and everything else that has
metastasized which is my favorite way of
government it has metastasized now to
we're in a disaster we provide every Tom
Dick and Harry two bags of ice so that
they can keep their hamburger cold or
there or there
clears beer cold and I went to Congress
and said this is out of control we're
spending tens of millions of dollars on
ice
so that a private citizen can keep their
food cold is that really a government
function even talking to conservatives
on the hill let alone Democrats or
liberals or anybody else I was a heretic
because of my movie we can't support
that because that's taking something
away from our constituents well but you
reckon that you realize it's a waste
right
why should we be doing that well we
can't stop it now yeah it's fascinating
and then you just get all these sort of
middle management rats and yeah man no
nobody's gonna give up that right so was
there anything else major between for
you professionally between 9/11 and
Katrina like what were you doing a month
before that was it still we had the ths
related no yes we had the Columbia Space
Shuttle disaster which we had to
coordinate with NASA because NASA was in
shock so we had to help them do all the
search-and-rescue from California to
Texas we had huge wildfires in
California that were just mass
kind of like have they've recently
experienced we had fires throughout the
West flooding in the Midwest we had the
tsunami in Southeast Asia I mean I could
go on and on and on yes my life was just
full of Hell from 9/11 on so until that
until the Katrina moment yes what was
the general feeling about you because
then now we'll get into this where you
were then used as well I was competently
what I was doing the White House always
turned to me to get things done it yeah
okay so I'll take you I'll take your
word but by and large you were thought
of as a competent executive and
everything okay so now now FEMA happens
I love the story that you told right at
the beginning because what a what a
perfect story of like just awful abuse
of power go check out my home right oh
yes you know the disaster areas and all
that kind of stuff how does it how does
it there was a certain amount of time we
knew that this thing was going to be
crazy right I mean how long before what
happened it was gonna be gassy because
we had I had gone to Congress and ask
for an appropriation pot I actually
wanted to spend to the tax money to plan
for 10 truly catastrophic disasters
something like a hurricane your former
New Yorker can you imagine category 5
going up the Hudson River
can you imagine something happening to
the LNG natural gas port in Boston a
terrorist incident there imagine the big
one hitting California or the New Madrid
fault imagine because New Orleans a
fishbowl a category 5 filling up New
Orleans so Congress had given me money
to start doing catastrophic planning for
these kinds of things New Orleans was
the first one we picked and when we did
a tabletop exercise to see if we could
coordinate the response the tabletop
exercise fell apart Dave so I knew
probably nine twelve months before
Katrina actually occurred that we
weren't ready so what does that actually
mean when you're doing a tabletop
exercise that that's just coordinating
all yes you know all the players in the
room and you pretend like you're going
through a disaster so what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what are the conflicts how do we
deconflict all these policy issues do we
have enough food
how do we get DoD to does dld have
enough equipment on hand to get in food
supplies and everything else you
exercise that around the table and
Louisiana fell apart yeah wouldn't work
was it right at the beginning of it that
you realized how severe it was I've been
criticized because in May of 2005 I had
my wife this is before for visiting for
Katrina in May of 2005 several friends
of mine including Colin Powell had said
you know what it's probably time to
leave and I I asked them seriously why
is it well you've done everything that
you can do in terms of trying to mold
DHS into what you think it should be and
nothing else is going to happen it is
what it is that you have you have fought
the good fight you've been here six
years
you know and of course my wife was weak
it's time to go back to Colorado let's
go back to Colorado and so I told an
e-card the White House chief of staff
in May of o-5 that I wanted to resign
and go back to Colorado and what
typically happens and II said can you
wait till Labor Day and go through one
more hurricane season for us and that'll
give us time to find a replacement now
when the president asks you to stay for
five more months sure I can do that man
Labor Day what was the date Katrina hit
it was on this night August 20 at Labor
Day you know whatever it is separate
days later yes okay so so it hits I mean
I can remember watching everything on
CNN at the time you mentioned Nagin who
is the mayor of the mayor of North
Lawrence how chaotic was it to
coordinate before you after you said
this this initial test had failed about
a year before it was it was virtually
impossible
so I land at the Superdome and the
Superdome well let's go back a step
yeah before I actually went to New
Orleans before the storm made landfall
max Mayfield who was the director of the
National Hurricane Center fellow okie he
and I got on the phone together and we
knew how bad the storm was going to be
but we could not
get the attention of state officials and
frankly we couldn't get the attention of
of the DoD and State Department other
people that would be playing the role
how is that possible you now have this
new DHS that was supposed to be quell
exactly later well because who's in
charge
I remember who's in charge well
everybody is now competing for their
pecking order because of DHS so I tell
max Mayfield would you please explain
because I'm gonna have bushes and
Crawford he'll be on the civets call
this top-secret phone conference video
and everything and I'll have the mayor
the governor of all the Gulf states
there Jeb will be there for Florida and
I need you to read them the riot act
about how bad this is going to be and he
did and then I pulled out an engineering
report that said the New Orleans
Superdome cannot even withstand a
category 3 based upon engineering
reports and the mayor just announced
that he's going to use the Superdome as
a shelter of last resort I'm screaming
on this call you can't do that that's a
huge mistake blah blah blah at this
point what did what category did they
think it was gonna be we thought it's
gonna be a 5 yeah it when it actually
hit it was a 3 but as we all know it
still ripped off the roof of the
Superdome so I knew going in it was
going to be bad I say all that to lead
to this one point the day that I'm
leaving to fly to Baton Rouge I remember
exactly where I was as I'm 195 one
around the Pentagon and I called Joe
Hagin the deputy chief of staff to tell
him that I'm headed to Andrews I'm going
down we're doing everything we can and I
said Joe but this is gonna be a cluster
because I can't get stuff coordinated
now and the storm hasn't even hit and
because I had already told them I wanted
to leave I said in an email to Hagin hey
can I quit now and of course everybody
picks that up
oh.what Brown doesn't care he's he wants
to quit before the storm hits that's
fascinating I mean I remember that yeah
sure I remember the hill and you were
just being sarcastic I'm a sarcastic guy
yeah I'm a total on the smart ass yeah
and so I had already agreed to stay
through Labor Day I
I was walking into a buzz saw and I'm
telling Hagen hey can I quit now and of
course the New York Times you know for
years all of my emails they see the
jokes that I crack because let me taste
them today not to get off the subject
you know but when when people are
suffering and people that are the rescue
workers the firefighters that are taking
people off roofs that are taking them
out of flooded homes they're working
their asses off they're tired they're
worn out they're stressed out you know
what the best thing to do is give him a
little humor yeah show him so you can
show a little humanity it's my
father-in-law was a schmuck I told you
delivered me as a surgeon he used to
talk about how he would relieve stress
in the o.r by cracking jokes and I've
always thought that the best way to
manage people in a time of stress is to
remind them of their humanity make them
laugh and if they can laugh for five
seconds that gets the endorphins running
and they can go out and keep working 24
hours a day seven days a week and I was
criticized for joking well you know
what's cruel because I've been asked
before well would you take any of those
emails back not a one of them because
you know what that made a staffer smile
that made somebody laugh and if you
don't understand the context and method
within which it was made then you are
deliberately just trying to make hay out
of something all right so let's get back
to that 10 seconds of videos you know
the exact line even though everyone says
a heck of a job brownie right they don't
even get that right you actually say
brownie you're doing a heck of it yes
thank you
yeah I just want to clean that up for
you because even that line babe they
don't get right ok how many days into
the hurricane was that oh gosh I want to
say is maybe four maybe five days I've
kind of I can flake time but for five
okay so four or five days yeah what now
I watched plenty of other video today of
what you were doing at the time and
you're standing there people can see
this on YouTube you're standing there
with giant maps of the whole area it was
very clear to me at least watching it
now that you had total command of where
things were who was supposed to be where
where water was going to hit harder and
yes
and Bush you know to his credit he it
seemed that he was listening along with
you and you know doing the best job I
think that he could after was it was it
three minutes after he says that that
you realized that the media went crazy
with it that was the minute he it was
the minute he said it because here's
what you don't know but you what most
people don't know is that I had told the
I called Air Force One and said when he
lands and gets here I need five minutes
before we do any sort of public photo-op
and when you even at my level of the
undersecretary even when you say I got
to have five minutes with the president
they still want to know why and I said
because he's got to understand before he
walks in front of cameras how bad things
are in New Orleans because we're gonna
leave that Air National Guard base get
on marine one and we're gonna fly to New
Orleans and he's gonna start seeing how
screwed up it is in New Orleans and I
want to make sure he understands that
before he gets there so sure we got
plenty time so we walk into the green
room I'm just starting to talk to the
president and they come in and say we
got to get moving
presses out here we're already running
late and they pulling that and I don't
have time to briefing my how bad it is
Wow so the moment and here's what really
happened Bob Riley who was the governor
of Alabama former congressman good
friend of mine we were doing great now
Alabama things were perfect in Alabama
perfect things were very good in
Mississippi it was just Louisiana so Bob
Riley being the supporting guy that he
is said oh by the way mr. president I
just want you to know the theme was
doing a great job in Alabama and that's
when the president said booth slapped me
in the gut and it was at that moment
Dave that I knew oh my god now three
things have happened the press knows
that I've got a relationship with the
president I have a nickname so I'm one
of the few people in the inner circle
that has a nickname to the press knows
how bad things are in New Orleans and
now both me and the boss look like we're
totally out of touch about what's
happening down the Gulf I mean there's
so much there
when you really realize how this was
happening yeah I I was if you watch that
closely you'll see me grimace because I
was just like holy yeah so okay so once
that happened how much of what your job
became was just dealing with media
craziness total totally not just the
media but now with a Secretary of
Homeland Security by the name of Michael
Chertoff who had never done any sort of
operations in his life he was an
appellate court judge yeah an appellate
court judge has clerks that bring your
briefs and say here's what we think your
decisions should be you sit behind the
desk and take your time you don't
realize that if you put off a decision
for 30 minutes in the middle of a
disaster that translates to three hours
and that cost lives so now I'm dealing
with a Boston DC that doesn't have a
clue what he's doing who's mad at me
because I'm on a Gulfstream trying to
get from mobile to Gulfport to Baton
Rouge to New Orleans and trying to keep
my fingers on everything going on who
tells me I'm tired of you flying around
because I can't find you and I'm
thinking you can't find me I'm on a
government Gulfstream that's got
saddling you can find me anywhere in the
world if you want to so tells me to
plant my button in Baton Rouge and I
turn to my staff and say this is the
beginning of the end they're after me
the media is after me turd offs after me
they're looking for a scapegoat I'm not
that's true but I mean I know what's
going on yeah are there any points of
criticism during that time that you
think are yes yes yes
I have a friend who is a psychiatrist at
the Kennedy School government and the
School of Public Health and I asked him
one time I said there was a point during
Katrina where you haven't known me but a
few minutes now but I think you can tell
I'm a pretty type-a person person pretty
energetic I'm pretty engaged in whatever
I do I'm passionate about what I do and
I asked my buddy I said so I know that
there was a point where I was just
frozen I literally could not make a
decision
what happened what happens he drew me a
cartoon and it's a cart you know the
great Wizard of Oz well it's a picture
of me in the first panel pushing all
these buttons and levers and turning
wheels and stuff and in the second panel
I'm staring at that same group of
buttons like what's going on and in the
third panel I've gone around to look
behind and all the wires have been cut
and he says that physiologically whether
it's it's a it's PTSD it's a natural
phenomena in the brain that when we are
trained like if I if I have trained
myself that when I tell my staff do X I
expect X to happen when you and I turn
on these lights or flip a switch we
expect the lights to come on now you add
all of the physical stress the emotional
stress and nothing is working the brain
starts to shut down and I will freely
admit and this is why I I to this day I
saw a firefighter the other day on the
street was having lunch and I walked up
to him and I said what are you doing
we've been doing training and I'm taking
the guys out for lunch and I said well
you don't know who I am but let me just
tell you that yeah you know making sure
those guys have time off and that they
get rest that's the most important thing
you can do because if they don't get
rest when they're fighting the fires
they themselves can become victims of
that disaster so we've got to learn to
train ourselves that when we're under
that kind of stress you have to be able
to step back and this is when I speak
about resilience I've learned to try to
teach audiences that we all have a
network and what we have to do is learn
that when we find ourselves in those
moments that we're either not making the
right decisions or we're not making
decisions we need some external force to
come in and kind of slap some sense into
us and say change your perspective what
I see is this if somebody had helped me
do that during Katrina
- still had the presidential bus run me
over
but at least I would have known why and
what was happy
but is that almost counter to the way a
sort of big government has to operate
you can to this right like you can't
people running around smacking people
are trying to get him to wake up because
the machine is so stiff right but but
what I needed and you could my very best
friend of my lawyer Andy Lester who went
through all the congressional hearings
with me to this day he'll tell you he
regrets not getting in his car and
driving to Baton Rouge because he's
watching this from a distance and he's
seeing what's happening and he knows me
well enough that he he could tell that
I'm just frozen like nothing's working
what do I do next and I just needed that
external force to come in and say you're
right nothing's working here's why let's
take inventory
have you slept no I haven't slept for
three days maybe you ought to go try to
take an ambien at least get four hours
of sleep it's that kind of stuff that
makes a huge man at that point also with
what was happening because of the media
you were sort of just in a feeding
frenzy oh it was like a self-fulfilling
absolutely you self-fulfilling it's
right you know to this day I am always
amazed I mean I could I could go through
the litany of falsehoods that I'm no
longer defensive about because they're
falsehoods and it is what it is and I
love talking about them in front of you
know corporate CEOs and titans of
industry who think they know that they
can run everything well let me tell you
someday the prefer the proverbial feces
is going to hit the fan and your company
and you're gonna want to learn these
lessons and learn them well that's why I
run a small business here what do you
make of just sort of the I guess this is
just part of the human condition the
idea that we always need someone to
blame now you are acknowledging that not
everything went right you didn't make
every right decision we're acknowledging
government over you know nonsense and
all that but just this need to blame
because I think you are one of the first
examples because maybe it was sort of it
that just at the beginnings of social
media or lines of just like let's just
take this guy I didn't know who he was
yes long enough and let's just destroy
it let's we'll destroy his career and
then we'll try to draw joy in life yeah
what do you what do you make of just
that general cycle
well there is a there's two ways to look
at it in Judaism there is the the
philosophy of finding the scapegoat and
putting all the sins of the community
putting all the sins of the village and
scape on the goat and throwing the gold
over the cliff well I think that really
is applicable to life in general and we
have through social media I can't I
can't even imagine what it would have
been like the social media back in 2005
it was brutal enough without it but I
think we have when you think about the
hierarchy of needs that people have
belong love power social media has
amplified all of those and the the
feeling of being superior to somebody
else so permeates our society that any
chance we have to squish somebody it
makes I don't know whether it's an
endorphin rush an adrenaline but
something but we now have this horrible
horrible desire to just destroy people
they have lives they have families now
some people maybe they deserve it maybe
them but I like to think that everybody
unless you're just totally a doofus
people are actually trying to do the
best they can
yeah I mean I'm a firm believer in that
yeah but yes of course there are people
that want to just destroy them
unfortunately I think social media
amplified you anything the best antidote
to that here's me because I refused to
stay down there were people have
actually advised me you need to slither
away and I was like are you kidding I
cannot wait for these congressional
hearings because I can't wait for some
dumbass congressman or dumbass senator
who thinks that he's God's gift to
creation to ask me a question because
I'm gonna tell him the truth whether he
likes it or not so let's talk about
those hearings a little bit when you see
it just any here right any hearing
related to anything it strikes me is
patently obvious that pretty much the
senators and congressmen have almost no
idea what they're talking about really
right but they've been handed a brief
career and they've been told by probably
you know handler or
whoever these are the three questions
you got to ask because we got to get you
on CNN tonight so then you can push this
and blah blah just did the hearings when
they're trying to unpackage all of this
do the hearings ever make things better
at the end like is there a hearing that
ends and then they go we really solves
the problems of why Katrina happened why
the levees fail what the problems were
with FEMA or other responders etcetera
etcetera rarely in fact let me tell you
it's actually worse than what you think
it right it's just more government
growing it's no it's more government
growing but to tell you how bad it
really is and there if as the
undersecretary if I'm gonna testify now
I was a private citizen when I testified
in the in the Katrina hearing yeah wait
just to be clear so how long after the
the yeah brownie you know until you till
you resigned well I actually
interestingly I resigned on September
11th of 2005 but then they came to me
and said oh we need you to stay on
because we've got to figure out just
what's going on because they're gonna
come after the administration so we went
to cloud we want to keep you in the fold
for a while so they kept me on as a
consultant force I want to say four or
five months afterwards and then I pulled
it you must be seriously pissed at that
but now you knew you were just yes so I
pulled the trigger and said no more
consulting I'm a private citizen and so
when I'm called to testify the White
House has to do one of two things they
have to be there except that I'm gonna
tell the truth
or they have to invoke executive
privilege and prevent me from testifying
and we deliberately set it up with Susan
Collins and Joe Lieberman for Senator
Lieberman to ask me a question so about
conversations with the President or the
White House so that when that question
was asked my lawyer could say my client
wants to answer the question but he
cannot if the White House is going to
invoke executive privilege which then
allowed senator Lieberman see how the
charade works yeah then allows senator
Lieberman to ask is there anyone in this
hearing room from the White House who
wants to invoke executive privilege and
of course the room silent that's pretty
sure that
and since her lieberman laughed and said
oh i'm sure there are plenty of people
from the white house here but apparently
nobody wants to invoke executive
privilege mr. Brown answered the
question and boom we were off to the
races
but to go back about just a regular
hearing yeah if an undersecretary or any
other government official is going to go
testify his testimony is cleared through
the Office of Management and Budget that
testimony is given to the senators and
congressmen in advance the questions are
given to the witness in advance it is a
show it is a production how much of it
also is that they're asking you things
as if everything sort of works perfectly
in any of the hearings you know in
Hillary the Benghazi and she knows where
they're asking minute by minute what did
you say then to this person that person
I mean I know in my own daily life you
ask me what happened three three days
ago at noon right you know I don't know
I have to think about it for a while but
me and maybe I can maybe man you know
you can make with it yeah but just that
they they're trying to get you on every
little thing plus the pressures of your
you're under oath you're the media
watching and everybody else and it just
seems like it's a recipe for nothing -
nothing good nothing substantial to come
out nothing substantial does come out of
them now I think there's an exception if
if in the House or Senate if they are
truly conducting an investigation and
here's how to tell if they're truly
conducting an investigation
they'll depose witnesses outside the
hearing room they will ask a witness
either voluntarily or with subpoena to
come in and subject to a deposition by
staff lawyers that's a real
investigation that's really sitting you
down and saying swear to tell the truth
the whole truth nothing but the truth
now let us ask you a series of questions
and that can actually result in
something productive now for the witness
you have to be very careful because like
anything else to your point what you
doing Wednesday at noon I you know I
went to went to this bagel shop down the
street and had lunch what was the name
of it well I think it was X they find
out actually you went to a burger stand
and had a burger now they got you in
perjury yeah it's crazy
so what was the resolution and when the
hearings ended like what do they do
something they issue a report there's a
report there a part brand and the report
what the report I get a kick out of this
because the report virtually
acknowledged everything that I had said
was wrong about the integration of FEMA
and these other agencies in the DHS
there was a virtual admission to that
then the things that they wanted to do
to correct were I don't want to over
exaggerate so let's just say 50% they in
essence adopted about 50% of the things
that I've been arguing about now is it
working it's not working because the way
things Google in DC whoever has the
money has the power and you can't one
down I'm using the FEMA current FEMA
director who's a former employee of mine
is an example you can't expect him on a
day-to-day what's his name Brock Brock
long okay used to be the at the National
Hurricane Center emergency manager in
Alabama he's a great guy I love this guy
probably should have said that because
that was like my family
well that the the the report oh the
reports so if you're fighting on a
day-to-day basis for your budget with
the Secretary of Homeland Security and
all the other under secretaries and then
when a disaster hits now you're the boss
and the secretary is subordinate to you
can you imagine doing that the private
sector one day you're the CEO but under
certain circumstances you as the CEO are
actually subordinate to somebody else on
your staff I mean that's an untenable
situation but that's kind of the
situation they created with the post
Katrina act that's crazy
so we touched obviously on the media
portion of this and I mentioned how when
I was googling you this morning at Anu
and research half the articles come up
are about the 10-year anniversary and
they're still attacking yes now again
you have sat here and acknowledged that
you did not do everything perfectly
right but what is it what do you make of
that in a more
one sentence about the media because I
talk about the media out here and I'm
extremely frustrated with mainstream
media and it's almost gotten to the
point where every time they write
something bad about somebody I start
thinking that they're actually the good
guy yeah because I see the way I do it
to me right that the new year really has
completely gotten out of control
they've lost they've lost all integrity
they've lost all this is what I do in my
own radio program is I don't tell I
don't ever try to tell people what to
think I try to give them a different
perspective so that they can with their
own minds maybe think about something a
different way
the media if you look for those ten year
anniversary things there's a one example
that just stands out to this day
irritates me I had the highest level of
security clearances with the CIA the NSA
I had a Q clearance with the Department
of Energy which means I had access to
all the nuke secrets and everything else
I mean I top-secret special excise
access program that was me I don't know
you're gonna drop any other secret
knowledge right yeah that's right so I
had all these clearances and everything
else Time magazine ran a story that I
had lied on my resume
now my first reaction when they ran that
story was sue the bastards I want to go
after all and then my lawyer starts
explaining to me okay first of all
you're gonna have to prove they did it
with willful malice because you're a
public figure then you're gonna have to
go through all of the strain and time
and energy of depositions and a trial
and hearings and you want to relive all
of that or do you really care about Time
magazine having some story that's now 10
12 15 years old about you lied on your
resume when you know what the truth is
and half of America knows what the truth
is and the other half of America you
don't really care about yeah
no but the media gets by with now I am
NOT I am NOT repeat NOT going down the
road the trunk goes down that says we
need to change the libel laws I'm just
pointing out that the media has this
amazing power and with that power I
believe comes responsibility and they've
abdicated the responsibility yeah you
know I'm 50/50 on reliable thing and
everyone that's watching the show knows
that I am an absolute free speech
Russell
yes specialized an absolute white
brother but I do believe in libel laws
and yeah I do believe we should hunter
to laws to protect privacy and a series
of other things I don't know I would
prefer that they don't be changed
because I don't think we need the
government doing it I don't think we
need more laws I don't think we need
more regulations or any of that right
yet there is something that I see so
consistently these days where they just
pick somebody and it's off I mean it's
often people that I have on this show
because they're right and think of
important conversations and we say one
thing here and then I read the article
about it the day after and it's
literally the reverse or they cut the
word not right you know or didn't it's
no way you know what I have found that I
find fascinating and I know that media
is in this transition you I mean look
what you and I are doing they hate what
you and I are doing right now because it
frozen fills our business model out the
window yeah I think what they like I'll
I'll be doing a story on air and I've
got the article in front of me and I'm a
kind of a grammar nut and I look at all
the holy crap an editor never even
looked at this The Wall Street Journal I
get to either stellar newspaper right
yeah I have they fired all their editors
I find so many grammatical errors
punctuation errors all I just think the
media is in this flux so you add the
flux with their agenda at times their
sloppiness you add all of those things
together the media is just not filling
their fourth estate responsibilities
yeah so how do we clean up some of this
government stuff I suspect although you
just said you're not with Trump on the
live level I suspect that there's a
certain amount of deregulation that he's
doing and cutting back some of these
agencies that you got to be pretty happy
with static about it when you think
about this all this is you'll find this
up as our example but whether it's here
in California are back in Colorado
wherever wherever we might might be I
challenge people watching this go look
at any government office and I would bet
it's the nicest office building in your
community
now wait a minute who paid for that the
guys in the garage who are coming up
with the next big thing of some startup
company or some guy that's working an 8
to 5 blue-collar job that it's got his
hands dirty those nails are cracked and
he's working with his hands like crazy
they're paying for that is it shouldn't
it be the reverse shouldn't the
government actually be in the garages
shouldn't they actually be the ones that
are in the office buildings that you
know they have to go up 20 elevators to
get their offices instead of having all
the edifice ha's that we allow them to
use and create and build we have this we
have this perverted sense that the
government and I think it's getting
worse that the government is the answer
to everything and that somehow
government is going to solve all of our
problems let me tell you the government
doesn't solve problems the government
causes problems so what would you say
the answer is related to so a DHS or
FEMA now or anything else I mean if
these things didn't exist I'm sure
somebody's watching this right tongue go
what do you mean I mean if these things
didn't exist well now you know
Norrell and still is below sea level
which is a hole in that you know let's
just talk about that for you like there
are a certain amount of people that now
say well wait a minute wait a minute
because they don't realize it then they
hear and they go wait a minute we have a
city that's below sea level that has all
of these you know structural problems
yes maybe we shouldn't be living there
anymore what do you say to someone like
that well first of all I think anybody
should be able to live wherever they
want to live if if I want to live next
to the National Forest in Boulder County
Colorado I should be able to do that but
then I should also assume the risk of
living there if I want to live on the
fault lines in California I should be
able to do that but I should assume the
risk yeah I think government has some
basic services to provide we all agree
the police protection fire protection
that's something we all want to pay for
but if you're going to deliberately
choose to live below sea level and then
why should I want to be very careful I
can feel it already why it's slippery
yeah yeah it's slippery because I think
they should be able to live there if you
choose to live there though it's the
responsibility of the taxpayers that
live there
to create those levees and build those
levees and maintain those levees because
I don't live there it's not my
responsibility I pay taxes to take care
of the hazards where I live and frankly
I don't think that government should
take care of all hazards because if we
tried to start if we start trying to
protect the American population from all
of the hazards that we face we will end
up with a totalitarian government
because there's too many hazards so this
is this is sort of the case where the
people that that were down there in New
Orleans that a lot it's not just I'm
sure most of them had or and I can't say
most but I'm sure a good portion at
least some people that had money had
insurance and probably had flood
insurance and everything else but it's
that afterwards all this federal money
comes in to help the rebuild but you're
saying there perhaps that that doesn't
quite make sense is that is that base
yes and there will be people who will
say oh my god the former director of
Federal Emergency Management Agency is
saying we should revisit absolutely we
have a concept of federalism in this
country we have federal state and local
government and at the top leg let's
reverse that we have the people we have
local government state government and
federal government that's the order and
what we have done is we have taken the
federal government and we've almost made
them the local fire department we've
almost made them the local police
department in a mini aspects that's
actually true TSA for example that we've
made them the local police department
that even though I'm gonna be a lawyer
here they have no law enforcement
authority they just think they do say
they have zero law enforcement authority
what does it actually mean they have
zero law enforcement authority I mean
okay if you go through and you've got a
knife in your pocket why oh then they
just hand you off to whoever the local I
think and you I gotta give a cop as I
gotta get a cop they can't they can't
arrest you they can't detain you they
can't do anything but they call
themselves officers because they want to
put on the mask of authority because
government always wants to put on the
mask of authority because that's how you
keep the citizens kind of subdued well
my whole point about FEMA becoming kind
of this first responder the more we rely
on the federal government to come in
after any sort of disaster
that weakens state and local governments
because they become more and more
dependent upon the federal government so
more and more things get nationalized
and the more things get nationalized the
more we turn into a Western European
socialist type government which we know
it's not gonna happen in our lifetime so
don't get me wrong I'm not on the
tinfoil hats not on now but but I do
believe that Republic's eventually fail
and we are on this path that if we keep
going down this path of throwing more
and more things up against the wall for
the federal government to to handle and
take care of we will end up as a Western
European socialist government and over
generations and generations that leads
to tyranny so then you must be digging
trunk on this all on this stuff
absolutely yeah
the thing the thing that bothers me look
the president wasn't my first choice and
I before we go too deep on him I do want
to mention that we are taping this a
little bit in advance of when it's going
to air so wasn't my first choice but
when it came down to the to the typical
dichotomy a Republican versus Democrat
you know I still think so I still want
to believe that Republicans are the
government of individualism and
individual liberty and everything
although I could argue that they aren't
necessarily that way and the Democrats
are moving to the hard progressive
almost Marxist left so when it comes to
the general election if I want to vote
for one of those two well I'm going to
vote for Trump I only say that because
he has totally upended what it means I
work for George W Bush who people
thought couldn't speak well but I
thought was smart knew what he was doing
I think Trump is smart I think he knows
what he's doing but he's the first
president in this age of Twitter and
Facebook and everything else and I just
don't think we've quite figured out how
to deal with that and quite honestly I
don't think he's quite figured out how
to deal with it he hasn't quite figured
out that as president if I say something
even innocuous
they're reading that in Beijing they're
reading that in Moscow they're reading
that in in Pyongyang they're reading it
everywhere and so he needs to be a
little more I just wish you would be a
little more circumspect in the use of
social media yeah all right enough about
Trump let's just talk about george w
bush for a second because you mentioned
he was he was your boss you know well
you know there was the caricature of
course of all the years of his
presidency that he was some sort of
idiot or you know yes he had a strange
way of speaking and kind of stilted and
Rose met you know wrote yes a lot of
that right he mixed up a lot of words I
mean tell me something about him that
maybe would give us a little other side
that we wouldn't know who there's a nod
nostalgia
that's one is there's a nod nostalgia
about him now because I see it from
people on the left all the time now
they're they're sort of galvanizing him
right there they're lionizing him now
because if you keep he and I were in the
limo we were in the beasts southern
california going back to marine one and
we're on these kind of rural areas and
people have lined the streets and Eddie
who is his agent in charge of
presidential detail he kept telling
Eddie and I wouldn't use these words
carefully
Eddie stopped the car these people want
to see their president it wasn't Eddie
stop the car they want to see me
Eddie don't stop the car because they
want to see you know hey it's me and
brown know they want to see their
president he had this understanding of
that office was his temporarily and he
was everybody's president and I saw that
in that car and then I saw it one time
in the Oval Office we were sitting and
and press office comes through with a
gaggle of kids and he stops the meeting
entirely and shows these kids I mean
they miss maybe sixth grade or seventh
graders shows them the resolute desk and
explains to them the history the
resolute desk and I'm sitting there like
ha ha I could watch this all day long
yeah
then a third story we heard he was
first presidential debate of the 2004
election he Jeb and I are in the car
we've been at some hurricane center
somewhere and Jeb turns to him and says
I think it's time to feed your hotel you
need to you really need to bone up and
study some and Bush is like now you know
I'm worth his ass
he was kind of a job he was a frat boy
with yeah with alone he was called a
frat boy jocular funny
crack jokes you know smarted off never
inappropriately but just ordinary human
being so these two brothers get in a
fight and I'm sitting in the jump seat
facing the president like I am you and
Jeb sitting there and they're arguing
about whether they should go back to the
hotel or now and Jeb looks at me and
says Helen and I'm like I am NOT going
to get the fight between two brothers
one who's the governor of a swing state
that we've got to win this election in
and the other guy happens to be the
president United States and my boss I'm
staying out of that fight boys and what
happened I stayed out of the fight and
and Bush went to that first debate and
lost big time to John Kerry there you go
well listen it's really been a pleasure
talking to you I hope we cleaned up some
of this stuff - did we hit everything
that that should have been hit on oh are
you kidding we could I mean I know we
got more days yeah yeah you got to go do
your radio show we're not too far from
here right but I suspect we'll do this
again I hope so yeah it was a pleasure
absolutely oh and by the way I want to
mention I you know I've talked to the
people over here for those of you that
follow us on patreon so many of you know
that my dog Emma is a rescue from
Hurricane Katrina and she's got a really
wonderful story so we did a video of
Michael meeting Emma before and I and I
told her story and that's on patreon and
for more on Michael you can follow him
on Twitter it's at Michael Brown USA
[Music]
you